[Music]
so the topic for today is how to migrate
windows were close to Google cloud and
this foundationally gets back to
Google's principle of meeting our
customers where they are and helping
them migrate to Google cloud and a more
open collaborative architecture for
applications at their own pace
and in a in a model that is more
comfortable for them some of that is
around rebuilding your applications but
a lot of that is also around lifting and
shifting of your enterprise applications
onto GCP or writing new dotnet
applications and that's the that's the
strategy behind making sure windows is a
Tier one platform a first-class platform
for right running Windows workloads on
GCP we have been added for a few years
now
we started in 2015 where we launched our
first Windows Windows server offerings
on GCP and since then we have been
pretty hard at work going adding
additional capabilities like sequel
server support HDS aport various types
of clustering and failover support as
well as two links around ornate and
PowerShell for making GCP a great
platform for us and today my colleague
Simon and I'm sure Wieck I'm part of the
product management team and Simon is
part of the engineering team we are
going to spend a bit of time kind of
walking through the migration journey
for windows were close to GC p and and
announce a few new products and
offerings that I believe will be super
super interesting to many of you in the
room the first of all I just wanted to
thank you for literally tens of
thousands of customers who are running
Windows were closed on GCP that may come
as a surprise to a lot of you because we
have been kind of creeping along with a
TV ad features getting customers along
the way I can happily say that the
number of customers who is running
windows were closed and GCP is actually
really sick
and so if any of you are kind of
hesitant and not sure if we are going to
take the first step because you know
there is not many too many customers on
that GCP on Windows that should
definitely not be a concern anymore
right and the conversation here more
about how to get there and the details
of the navigation process more so than
if so when we go out and talk to these
tens of thousands of customers or a
finality of them like you know many of
you here why are they running Windows on
GCP couple of couple of course points
come out loud and clear so the number
one point that comes out loud and clear
is the our Google's position on being
open know not we are not a vendor who
wants to lock you into proprietary
technology or proprietary platform we
are open right and I think a lot of you
have this vision of running your
applications in an open and dynamic
cloud where you can migrate across
various public cloud platforms as well
as on-premises and that's some of the
announcements that having made this week
the second is the Google did everything
we have amazing infrastructure network
security efficiency etc etc and all of
those capabilities applied to windows
were closed as well we are not going to
touch on them too much because this is a
pretty big top Windows is a pretty big
topic but those those play a big role
the third thing that we hear is that
Windows is a big part of any enterprise
data center or workload so as customers
move as you move that many of your
workloads the Windows dependency
components need to be supported well and
that it makes up a significant
percentage of the workloads and the last
one that comes across pretty pretty
frequently also is the data gravity and
integration with Google applications if
many of our customers have very
significant amount of data on GCP as
well as they're building new your
applications with dartnet or net core
and other other languages on GCP and if
there is a Windows platform dependency
running them on TCP just makes it much
more easier simpler secure than running
it outside so the question then becomes
how do you get there what is the journey
right and and having kind of observed
this across many many customers this is
kind of the simple pattern that we see
again and again the journey starts with
hey I really don't know what to start
and they go through an assessment
planning and a migration phase then they
kind of think about how do you operate
large complex Windows environments on
GCP and then there's simultaneously with
that or subsequent to that there's a
phase of how do we actually modernize
our Windows applications on GCP and
we're going to touch on them all of
these topics today and it's a pretty
broad span of activities and we want
actually do more if you think so we
would not necessarily have time to get
into the details of many of these
components but there are number of
individual sessions that have already
happened or happening in in the next two
days to talk about these in details so
these are some of the key questions that
we hear from our customers as they get
started on migrating their Windows
Windows components or applications to
GCP the first one is how do I start the
next big thing that is very window
specific is how do i how does the
licensing thing play out do you have to
rebuy all my microsoft licenses on GCP
and lastly what exact technologies do we
use for migrating the VMS and how do I
test and make sure everything is working
together and let's touch on those
questions but before getting into the
details and just given the scope or the
information I just wanted to highlight
this migration Center website which is a
cloud.google.com slash migrate is the
single place for accessing all the
information regarding migration and you
can access it at any point of time to
get additional information our about our
products our partners products our
service indicator partners products and
offering so on and so forth so the first
piece of the journey starts with
discovery assessment and planning and
what we have done here is that we have
closely partnered with a large number of
ISV vendors like large with a strategy
on wrist network low demise who have
built tools to discover environment and
help in the planning process
and many of these tools are free for
customers migrating to GCP it's not free
for everybody but what we have done is
structured the agreement that if you
want to use any of these tools just
reach out to us and you can have pretty
much unlimited usage of many of these
tools as you migrate this these migrate
to GCP for Windows and other workloads
and what these tools does is that it
kind of gets you an understanding in a
in a very non intrusive way a map of all
the applications running in your data
center there's a couple of sample
outputs many of these vendors are there
in our show floor you can see a demo you
can also see a demo in the
infrastructure upgrade Pavillion in the
show floor but it kind of lays out that
what are the critical applications what
are the dependencies what other you know
if I move this workload what other
workloads gets to us and so on and so
forth and one of the thing that I we see
a lot of our customers doing is trying
to identify those workloads that are not
highly interlinked not highly critical
to get started and then move on to more
and more complex workloads to to to
migrate to the cloud ideal examples of
workloads would include things like test
and dev environments or pre-production
environments and other things to kind of
try out the how this thing works out the
other impressive thing that we have
these vendors I see vendors have done
working in close collaboration with us
in that it actually provides you very
clear TCO outputs of how these tools
kind of as you migrate to the cloud how
does this thing play out from a
financial perspective right so you can
do a cost-benefit analysis virtually
doing nothing was just moving to us and
while talking about the cost benefit
analysis in financials one of the
biggest things that that that are
hindering or is a concern for a lot of
customers migrating Windows work through
the cloud is the licensing component of
it and I just wanna spend one or two
minutes just talking about that in
little details the first thing to
remember is that if you have a Microsoft
Enterprise Agreement customer there are
two primary tenants that that that
applies to license compliance
number one is that the licenses that he
bought from Microsoft using enterprise
they need to be need to be used in an
infrastructure that is dedicated to you
and the next one is even when you're
using let's say Windows Server licenses
in an infrastructure that is meant for
you you cannot move those licenses
around multiple servers in any time less
than 90 days so what does what does
means is that for many public cloud the
way it is architected we create large
pools of physical infrastructure and
move VMs around and a lot of times the
VMS are moved around even for upgrading
the underlying physical infrastructure
even if the certain hosts are dedicated
to you so it's not Google specific for
lot of will pretty much all of the
public cloud vendors what it means is
that you have to till now by something
called a splat license for running
Windows on public cloud systems and
apply is amazing for very specific
workloads like for example yeah and a
slide is basically Windows licenses or
other Microsoft license you can't buy by
the second so it's very very good for
very high spiky usages where you are
using something for five seconds for
hundreds and hundreds of course and
don't do it use it for the year it's
much very advantageous for those types
of workloads to use bla but on the other
hand if you have already a like your
basement full of Windows licenses or
sequel server licenses and you don't
want to spend money on rebind those
licenses and they can be costly they can
be up to sixty percent of the price of a
VM it can become a prohibitive expense
right so that has been historically a
challenge but I'm happy to announce that
I next we have announced the beta of our
salt and and bi world offering and this
is really really exciting because it
allows you to bring your enterprise
license agreement into GCP so what it
basically means is that you do not have
to spend a huge amount of dollars buying
slot licenses if we have Enterprise
Agreement licenses for Windows Server
sequel server you can dump them on GCP
run them on the salt in a node
and not only do you get benefit of the
licensing it also has a lot of the
inbuilt reporting that in case you get
audited by Microsoft you can leverage
these reports for compliance purposes
and you have seen a huge amount of
interesting that I'll find the beta
customers we have been working with so
definitely you know encourage you guys
to try it out and figure out you know
dig into this a little bit more and
loosely associated with licensing cost
it's not necessarily just the byl the
Google cloud platform itself has a large
number of primitive that helps you in
optimize licensing and infrastructure
cost for example things like per second
billing custom VM sizes preemptable VMs
right sizing recommendations so that you
are not using extra cores which usually
translate to extra licensing costs so
all together creates a very significant
difference between what you may have
spent on licensing before to move to a
public cloud than doing with it with us
now so definitely we are very excited
and we expect a lot of customer adoption
and excitement around that once you have
figured out the licensing and how to
migrate the next big thing is how do we
actually do the migration and I will
hand it over to my colleague Simon to
kind of walk through a quick demo after
thank you so much so this both strata it
actually makes it very very easy to
migrate your VM running on private
premises all the way to Google clouds
when you use VAR strata you can
basically take your applications which
are up and running with Windows or with
Linux as well without installing
anything on the VM without changing your
source code basically just taking over
those VM VMs all the way into the clouds
now the solution allows you to do easy
testing is the rolling back if you move
the VMS into the cloud and then you
decide to move them back you can do that
too
also if you have waves of machines for
example cluster that is multiple VMs
working with each other with
dependencies you can use the feature
called runbook automation which allows
you to move all those VMs together such
that the dependencies will be preserved
well I'm going to show you a small demo
alright thank you so what we have here
is the vSphere web client and I have we
were a data center with multiple VMs in
this case two windows VMs what I'm doing
here in one of those we amps is running
regular legacy dotnet framework
application it is hosted on is and just
to show you what that is it's open
source tool called Orkut for content
management it's currently running on
premises and we'll try to move this
application all the way into into the
cloud so I'm already have all the setup
baked in so all we need to do is going
into this wellö strata operations tab
which you need to install as part of
your with fear ever client and then we
have this option of my grades what it
does it opens up a wizard which we need
to fill up to say how is this we am
going to be named once it's ported over
to a Google cloud and then what is the
VM configuration in terms of CPU and RAM
this storage policy how how we are going
to handle all the rights and then the
networking in this case I'm going to
create a femoral IP address so that we
can try and access this VM on Google
cloud later on and then I'm basically
going to run this operation now this
operation can take about 10 minutes to
complete but what we will see eventually
is I already have one of those machine
smooth I moved the wind one when we just
started this presentation so I can show
you that this BM one is actually
accessible through the external IP
address on Google cloud this is the
machine ok and all the effort that they
had to do is just install the VMware
extension for Vella strata and also
install the server side part of well
strata on my project at Google Cloud and
then create the VPN interconnect between
the on-premises and the cloud I did all
the set up ahead of time but basically
you get once you get this set up up and
running and we have everything
documented on a cloud of google.com you
can migrate your VMs for free without
changing anything in the source code or
even without the VM being aware of the
fact that it's moving moreover there is
no downtime that's caused by the fact
that you were migrate those VM so it's
really powerful solution that you can
use even today if you want to migrate
your windows we amps onto a Google cloud
so let's switch back to civic thank
Simon and this pretty awesome and by the
way just to highlight you can see the
GCP is automatically recommending how
you can optimize VM sizes to save
certain amount of dollars and all of
those numbers are probably going to be
doubled because it's going to also save
Windows licensing costs as you as you go
through this phase just wanted to
highlight its I switch back to the
slides please okay
so the next piece of the journey now
that we have landed your existing VMs on
GCP is how do we operate and manage this
environment in a day to day basis and
over here are some of the key questions
we hear is how do I deploy new VMs on
apps on GCP is it secure how is the
performance how do I manage my
application do I have to do all that
stuff that I was doing in the data
center on GCP or there's better way of
achieving the same thing and so on and
so forth and a couple of points in that
direction so once you have migrated you
may have needs for new VMs and new
applications to be spun up and what you
will see you at GCP is that we have a
very very large library of
pre-engineered pre-tested pre-optimized
google google windows images that you
can spin up whenever you want with
incredible licensing and all this
management tied into GCP in case you
can't find this exactly what application
you are looking for what you will also
find is a large number of prepackaged
applications as part images that are
available in our marketplace and the
building the licensing the usage are all
tied to your overall GCP account so it's
really really easy for you to spin up
applications that you might want from
ISV vendors as you can see over here I
know many of you are have much more like
more strict and stringent security
requirements I just want to highlight
that all of these VMs from us or from a
marketplace can actually be done on our
shielded VMs which makes them even more
secure to run these your workloads for
Windows on GCP and this is in addition
to all these other great security
features we have already tied into GCP
the other thing that I want to also mine
highlight over here is our huge
differentiator for for for follow from
an operational lifetime perspective
which is which is live migration so
whenever we have to make infrastructure
form where updates to our underlying our
underlying public cloud platform using
live migration technology we make sure
that
your workloads get impacted and there is
continued operation so if you're worried
about hey I'm gonna start running my
Windows applications here does it you
know is it is it reliable are you going
to suffer downtime the answer is that
you can be completely comfortable
they've got you covered we have live
migration and many other technologies to
which applies for Windows as well as any
other workloads to provide higher uptime
so I'm also pleased to announce a number
of new additional services as promised
we are working on the GCP patch and
config management the purpose of this is
to make sure that when you are running
all these Windows VMs as well as Linux
and other VMs you do not have to
manually keep on patching and extending
your own prima applications to GCP this
is a very simple flick through console
integrated into the GCP console which
allows you to understand how many of
your VMs that are running are are at a
certain patch level such a convict level
based on best practices and if they are
not at power you can set policies to
either upgrade them or take additional
steps you can also drive policies saying
that all the VMS running in a dis
projects needs to have these
configurations because that's what you
mandate that's what is secure and that's
how you know you kind of in for
standardization across your fleet of VMs
if we detect any of these VMs do not
comply with these policies you can
trigger actions including like you know
highlighting them in a report and other
things so that it makes it much much
easier for you to manage this large
fleet of VMs right from the console
without having to use third-party tools
or extending on-prem tools and we are
looking for alpha partners to test this
out we expect to get this all sometime
before the end of the year and my my
colleague Ravi here just in a stop feel
free to stop by and ask him for for
additional details also very very you
know excited to announce our managed
sequel offering on on GCP so we already
already had a large number of
standardized sequel images that are
applied optimized for DCP you could have
spent up but one of the things that we
heard repeatedly from our customers is
hey I have a 1,000 2,000 3,000 instances
or sequel I really don't want to manage
that once there ever GCP you guys should
be doing more of that so that I can
focus more of my efforts and higher
order business business value generating
problems and that's what we have so you
can actually spin up these sequel VMs
and we will manage them for you under an
SLA is fully compliant to Microsoft work
environments and takes another load of
you Sam very similar to sequel ad is
another integral part of of GCP and we
already had any service but we are happy
to learn of the beta or coming soon for
the beta for the manage ad service and I
will hand it over to my partner Simon
again to kind of walk through that and
show you a quick demo Thank You Subic so
we've managed service for Microsoft
Active Directory what you get is
Microsoft Active Directory but hardened
and managed by Google you get the system
configuration parching replication all
of those hustles that you typically need
to deal with when you manage Active
Directory yourself you get that all off
set and taken care of by Google
operations team and our service that we
just announced recently and the bet of
Microsoft Active Directory managed by
Google is it's gonna be announced very
very soon so look out for that if you
want to join the Alpha and Express more
interest there is a link on the slides
that you can join and get some more
details you can extend your existing
Active Directory from on premises all
the way to Google Cloud and manage the
identities in a unified way using this
offering I want to show you a small gem
of that what you see here is our cloud
console and on the security tab there is
a new option called manage Microsoft ad
this is where we can create your own
Microsoft Active Directory domain so all
I need to do just
going into the create ad domain and add
some name networking settings and which
region I want to deploy this Active
Directory set up and then I can also
name the admin user this admin user is
what you get so that you can manage all
your identities using that user you can
also delegate starting from this user
too to other users that you might create
basically we can use the same familiar
Active Directory tools like Active
Directory users and computers to manage
all your Active Directory needs but this
user is gonna be your gateway into the
manager Active Directory and you will
get full control of all the users
computers and other Active Directory
objects that you you might create once I
hit create here it's gonna take about 40
minutes to create so I already have a
few domains out there once I create this
domain you can be sure that it's all
managed by Google there are multiple
domain controller instances that we spin
up so that it's good for redundancy and
for overall health of your Active
Directory setup alright thanks Thank You
Simon okay so now that we have covered
the assays plan and migrate and operate
let's talk a little bit about
modernization because that's I I believe
where all of us wants to be just a
question of when and how right so for
modernizing Windows applications on GCP
or dotnet applications on GCP so we
provide a number of instruments we
provide containers on TCP that kind of
helps you streamline the operations and
with their vendor multiple sessions
around that are next we provide dotnet
client libraries for all GCP api's so if
you are a dotnet developer or your
clients are Dornier developers you can
rest assure that even if they can build
in a language that's they're comfortable
and run those applications seamlessly on
GCP and in a lot of cases even if
they're not running on GCP you can still
access these api's from on-premises or
other clouds it's tightly integrated
with the visual studio so once again
making sure that the developer
experience is seamless as they migrate
from other cloud platforms to GCP and
the last one is we have invested a lot
in making sure our strap driver star
technologies are integrated into the
darknet platform so you have much more
visibility into what's going on and
what's working what's just work working
not on GCP now let's talk about how ok
so before we get into the D so at the
same now we're really excited to
announce is the availability of the
coming soon as in we are working really
really closely with Microsoft on Windows
Server container support in gke we are
really excited because this allows you
to provide a seamless operating
experience across Linux and windows
containers on GCP and really optimize
your operations and my colleague Venkat
here is is it will be around to answer
any questions after the session so now
that we have talked about all these
instruments that we have at our disposal
let's talk about how you kind of use all
of them to modernize your applications
so the first and the easiest case is
probably new your existing app that can
be rewritten or do you want to rewrite
for GCP and over here you have GCP
dotnet api is various types of tools we
talked about later we visual studio
integration and the stack drivers to
rewrite those applications and run that
on App Engine which is entirely cloud
native you don't have to manage it you
don't have to think about it it kind of
Lots magically but we also know that
that's probably going to be a small
percentage of the overall application
that you manage so what do you do with
them so there are going to be some
applications that you are going to be
running on dotnet that can be converted
to dotnet core applications and we
understand that dotnet core is not
really you know
as as as expansive as to write all
applications but a certain set of
applications you can migrate and what
you can do is that as you review
architect your applications to door net
call you can actually run dotnet core on
a Linux on a GK a server so what happens
is your overall operating platform is
now much more open because dartnet can
dotnet core can learn on linux and it's
moving more and more towards open source
now there are going to be a set of
applications where you can't convert to
dotnet this may be traditional dotnet
applications maybe even windows 32
applications what you can do there is
convert them to gke containers on and
run them on manage GK service on Windows
so what happens is that you have not
it's not completely open it's not
completely scalable you still have a
Windows footprint there but you have
actually taken a lot of the pain away in
custom management of the platform by
making it part of the overall GK
solution and finally there are going to
be Windows applications that can't even
be continued eyes maybe they are really
old or have some special quirks that
stops it from being on their eyes and
for those applications you can still
move them to GCP like we talked about
and you still get all the benefits of of
managed managed services licensing
things like managing such groups that
makes it easier for you to scale up and
scale down the research usage and so on
and so forth and hopefully you know
initially when you will start most of
the application that you have are going
to be in the bottom part of the slide
but as time goes by you kind of start
moving app smooth and more up the stack
and at some point of time you're in a
much more free and open world than you
are right now so that's how this thing
hangs together and I would hand over to
my colleague for this final time to kind
of walk through a demo of how all these
things work together thank you so big
so can you switch back please
all right thank you so we are going to
see a demo how some of the tools that
Subic mentioned earlier for
modernization are playing together when
you develop your dotnet or dotnet core
application in order to understand that
then what we thought it's going to be
very useful to see the storyboard first
and then we actually will go through the
demo so at first we'll see application
which is quite typical once you start
modernizing your dotnet framework -
dotnet core and this is the application
with three layers you have front-end
talking to a back-end talking to a
database all those are micro services
that run on kubernetes cluster on a
managed jiggy and there is a problem
there in order to understand and
diagnose the problem we'll use tools
such as tag driver debugger with lock
point support for dotnet core and we'll
try to support the problem will then
make an update into the code using the
tool that we are happy to announce today
called cloud code for Visual Studio code
with dotnet core support and then after
the deployments using that tool is
complete we'll see that the application
is all opera up and running again on
Google Cloud so now let's please switch
back to my laptop what you see here is
the guestbook application that I just
mentioned earlier so you can type some
text and then you you should be able to
post this text into the guestbook which
should store it eventually in some
database but it takes some time and
apparently doesn't work so probably it
happened to some of you in the past that
it works on my machine but when you move
it to a different environment it stops
working for some reason so the problem
might be not necessarily relevant to the
code but more so relevant to the changes
between different environments and so we
want to understand what the problem is
so I open the tool called stackdriver
debugger stackdriver debugger
is the tool that allows you to
troubleshoot applications live in
production doing what we call snapshot
debugging as well as attaching work
points I'll talk more about the lock
points experience with lock points you
can add additional logging statement in
already running application without
changing its source code but with adding
more context for you to travel shoot the
problem what we'll do here is adding a
statement on line 46 this is the code of
the application that your so earlier I'm
adding a lock point I can make it
conditional but I'll just for simplicity
we'll add it with always true statement
and I'm going to run to write backhands
addr
equals basically there is a variable on
line 46 it's sending requests to a
back-end but I don't know what back and
address is that so for that I'll try to
print that value into into the log okay
so once we do that we basically added a
lock point without changing a cord the
way it works is that we which is
stackdriver in this case react to
callback so once the the code pass where
we added the lock point is being hit
there will be a callback that will send
the log message that we just added into
stock driver logger so that you will be
able to see this additional log
statement that wasn't there before when
you actually deployed the application in
the first place this allows you to
troubleshoot applications without the
need to redeploy by adding more log
statements it's it could be very useful
because sometimes deployment could be
stressful operation also with some of
the safe deployment practices out there
it might take some time to actually roll
out the changes that you're making into
your application so this could become
very handy so let's try to execute this
again and so by refreshing this page I'm
actually trying to execute the same code
pass where we added the lock point and
so now if we refresh we should see that
it actually added this log statement
back and addr equals and this is the
actual value of the variable which
wasn't known before so you can see here
that there is a typo in backhand and
this is likely why the application is
not working now I want to deploy a
change which will fix this application
so for that I will use a tool called
cloud code for visual studio code this
is the new extension that we are pleased
to announce today
it supports for programming languages
out of the box and dotnet core is the
fifth language that we add to that with
this extension you can browse your
Combinator's cluster objects see what
ports and deployments and other objects
you have you can connect to specific
ports for troubleshooting you can get
more details about what's currently
deployed and where without memorizing
all the cube CTL commands for managing
and working with kubernetes cluster so
it really streamlines the inner and
outer loop of your development
experience so let's make a change here
and change back end to back end and then
I want to deploy it in order to deploy
all I need to do is starting a new
command which is cloud code deploy what
this will do it will ask me what profile
do I want to use so this extension
supports multiple profiles and you can
think about profiles as different
environments that you might have in your
application
so maybe I want to deploy it to my local
machine and see if it works but I can
also choose a different environment in
my case I choose to actually deploy it
into a Google cloud and what happens now
as I speak is that the application is
packaging all my code pushing it into
GCS bucket
and then we are going to invoke a tool
called cloud wield which will try to
build all all the code of my application
create a container image and then push
that container image into my cluster all
of that is going to happen completely
automatically without you needing to
deal with all of the smaller pieces of
how do I build how do i D bug and how do
I deploy it's all taken care of by this
tool now the deployment by itself can
take a few minutes here so we'll just
let it run but what what I wanted to
show is basically how handy this tool
can become in your inner loop when you
try to develop your application and
repeatedly debug and deploy them all the
way into the cloud so to just sum up
what we saw today we actually can
develop applications using dot and
framework move them all the way to
Google cloud with Bella strata and then
if we want to modernize we can move to
dotnet core use any of google cloud
public api using dot and client
libraries and then use tools such as tag
driver debugger with lock point support
and visual studio code extension called
cloud called with dotnet core support to
be able to build the bug and deploy your
modernized application on Google cloud
ok so that's all I have and I'd like to
hand over back to sue ik Thank You Simon
[Applause]
so hopefully so first once again
thanking you guys for your trust many
many of our customers and many of you
for trusting your windows workloads to
be run on GCP and as you can see just
this week there are six major
announcements on Windows platform where
we are going to make it much more robust
easier to manage easier to scale on GCP
the beta for Soltan and bi o l massive
for traditional Windows workloads from a
licensing perspective cost more for the
prospective beta of the managed IT
Service primera once again critical
Windows workload we want to make it
easier for you to deploy and manage
alpha for - sequel batch and config
management service windows for gke and
dotnet core support for cloud code for
visual studio and again as you can see
we have trying and we have executed on
and giving you everything you need from
migrating
operating and modernizing your
applications and this is just the start
and many more exciting things are going
to come you know but you don't have you
know and those are all going to add on
to make us a better and better platform
to modernize your applications so these
are some other sessions that that that
will be of interest some of them
actually happened but you can find their
recordings on YouTube and many other
platforms and we'll really appreciate
your feedback
[Music]